e aí galera que assistir o canal tudo
bom vocês
olha só mandam senai estou só tá
faltando botar o coração pronto e ainda
se mexem 3 ver no vídeo e olha só que
beleza já fiz um vídeo aqui falando
japonês nec
eu sou fluente a mágoa quer dizer o wo
para quem não sabe eu sou doente não
está em clima de copa né como está sendo
a rússia nada mais justo do que fala
russo eu digo e repito que a gente
precisa aprender outras línguas e também
fazer as outras pessoas aprender a nossa
língua às vezes fico pensando se é bom a
gente fala também porque ninguém quer
falar nós né qualquer lugar do mundo
falou a palavra errada a galera já falou
disse que a palavra word o seu voto
word work pessoal não entende não faz a
mínima questão de entender só porque tu
não tá falando direito a dora chega e
tratou de fora aqui no brasil fala é o
tea mossa paulo querido cara ele disse
eu te amo são paulo killing no brasil
obrigado mas é importante saber por
exemplo eu fui do programa de luciano
huck e fiquei brincando com libras ela
não gostou e eu por ser ignorante não
saber o fim de toda a galera fazendo
brincadeira eu queria até pedir desculpa
que eu não quis ofender ninguém
acho que assim ninguém deixar claro que
eu amo todos vocês
a situação com ignorância desgraça eu né
conversando com a galera galera estamos
muito fundido não sei que eles é que lá
e falei [ __ ] a quimera que eu posso
fazer para remediar fui tentar fazer uma
aula de libras perdeu no meio da música
deficiente auditivo né escreveu pra mim
que é legal você querendo aprender
libras
eu peguei o celular e mandar um áudio é
deus
portanto é muito importante você
aprendeu transe como também em clima de
copa né vamos falar rosso vamos lá não
dizer bom dia em bolso a escrita aqui
pra mim já não vai não vai
que dobre outra
aqui eu já me arromba tiverem carrros eu
precisar de informação para chegar a
algum lugar eu parar em alguém fala bom
dia pessoal dobre outro falou obrigado e
vou embora dobra na outra esquina dobrou
outra do breu trapo boa tarde boa tarde
do prédio em que ela pode dobrar dobrei
de dobradinha agora está até agora mais
fácil ver boa noite boa noite meu deus
eu acho que fico mais com boa tarde
mesmo clima aqui fosse barros eu ia
acordar meio-dia só a boa tarde a todo
mundo que passasse e dormir de novo
quando precisar conversar com ninguém
pessoal passando eu dobrei o presidente
do pleito começou a escurecer ficou de
noite as pessoas vão me dizer boa noite
fico eu tenho até medo que corresponde
ao escutar o negócio no meio da rua
é de louvar você me respeite e faz a sua
mãe não se fala da [ __ ] não vê obrigado
a logan daryl vaz lobo amaro vaz lobo
agora vamos ver me desculpe isv na minha
é me desculpe mas button que fizeram
vida você tá rosa lá vamos ver como
seria um pedido de desculpa dele sem
rosto tá me desculpe eu sou uma vergonha
para o meu país meus pais têm vergonha
de mim eu sou o pior espermatozóide que
um brasileiro já pode reproduzir
prometo não ter mais relações sexuais
com ninguém para não correr o risco de
reproduzir
me desculpe moça e desculpe rússia
vamos ver acho para achim k paz
organização está nem aí ela disse que se
estiver sozinha e essa marcha sequer
marcador o brasileiro o jucá taliban mas
para existe jab chamis em massa sexo no
esquema e baixo custo o banheiro estava
de suas 13 dinheiro e jelly de buscar a
companhia já era assim eu chegamos à
conclusão que é muito melhor eles
aprenderem pedir desculpa e lembra como
tite sempre demora pra botar o filme vão
tentar pedir em russo para ver se ele
bota logo já tite por favor
bota o firmino tite pode estar zabrze
feminino a votar em mim que mais podia
acha se eu vou ter o inda som é o cara
mais limpo do mundo em russo sberbank r
não adianta meu amigo é nenhuma língua
você é bonito
seu futuro é ser igual ao seu pai você é
só engraçado mesmo e é se quisesse não
funcionam galera vou tentar falando
depois ainda montou na rússia virou um
negócio
vamos lá com licença meu amigo onde fica
a lanchonete mais próximo da mãe de
jéssica
parece que tá todo mundo preso na rússia
smith madrugada de 10 de chances não dá
smith e moído omc esse 8120 royce group
mas aí o resto já vi a língua embolou
para aberto aqui ele já encheu o saco
satisfeito às vezes já acusa de cisnes
madrugada eles acham da acompanhar
também japonês até se não tomou da
participante kayaya lado conectar meu
deus só queria uma lanchonete em breve
meu harry potter compromisso nem jorge
taxa tomodati a china tomou kachani a
subir mantém o a taxa a china tomou
dashti banri kaeda aynaoui dodô já é
melhor que entendeu mas em russo é muito
shellshock fica quente que pinta
inventei janela em nada nunca pude fazer
isso lá como fazendo isso vá com um
temos que ser bem educado por licença
moço mas você pode verificar-se morreu
algum animal embaixo do seu braço e 2040
nogent lena olin o número alencar com
evo x democrata pode buscar aquela
pessoa se tóquio não tome banho só
partiu de salvador onde é possível do
ponto se pode perguntar também você sabe
me dizer se algum caminhão de
desodorante virou perto de
em um lixão o gent livros casa tinha que
tocar conta disso dera poder no seu
valor o que vão quem eu entendi o
desodorante aqui hoje livros casa tinha
que tocar conta disso era o jogador
antes durante e rússia desodorante é ver
o menino chico buchinho desde o da lei
do chamado atravessador e hoje não só
que está porque acho que eu preciso de
um dano danilo chutou basicamente à seca
que eu ia falar na rússia ia ficar só do
boa tarde com a galera e pedimos
odorante do brinde os admiradores fofa
do brasil deve liberar hoje todo mundo
chegar pra mim faço que tinha turística
caxinas neste mercado disse peter fish
metralhadoras iranir hoje o presente e
tal mas é preciso falar uma frase traz o
hexa brasil
dagsa brasília já que o hexa é nós o
féla da wta tarde o blu um macho blu um
macho bloom box acho bluebox jogos a
mais o brasil daqui encontrar uma pessoa
com mau hálito na rússia como você fala
com ela em russo isso o la com licença
sempre muito educado em você beijou um
cubo de um elefante
smith ou seja com licença e zenit vai
por isso lá vai utilizar de sítios de
lona vai perdoar mais adiante na mesma
zona
os limites vai doar sangue zona o início
e um fim eu sei o negócio é o mei o
limite para as lonas de lona
nick zona não dá pra falar isso aqui
acho que é mais fácil comprar uma escova
e pasta de dente entregar a pessoa vai
entender isso é difícil eu acho que
chegou a prender não e as crianças a
rússia está a falar é espero que tenha
gostado esquece que gostei tas cqc já
tem um monte de vídeo carregada e mais
cliques gostei que isso é muito
interessante que você não é inscrito meu
canal se inscreve também fazer parte
desses 30 milhões aí a gente crescer
mais mas estamos junto desculpa demora
para postar vídeos aproveitou fazer mais
vídeo 'tamo junto' beijam e é mais é
nóis vai quem quer